super far right-wing believes that you
should have an ar-15 right they believe
you have an ar-15 you have the right to
carry that without so much as a permit I
don't think that that is any more
extreme I think that is far more
reasonable than someone who believes
that a serial rapist should have the
right be entitled to a trial a civil
trial against you for blowing his head
off three home invaders they were
teenagers they were shot dead
so the Oklahoma victims one of the
victims father is now complaining and
there's the thought of legal action
because he is saying the ar-15 gave the
homeowner an unfair advantage yes one
could almost argue that that is the
point of an ar-15 the whole purpose to a
firearm is to create an unfair advantage
because you know who has an unfair
disadvantage their entire life the woman
the disabled person the smaller man the
person who's had their lunch money
stolen the person who would have no
chance to protect life and limb and make
sure that their family gets to continue
for generations of their own would it
not be for modern weaponry that's the
entire it's the great equalizer it's a
beautiful thing the advantage that I
want the homeowner to have over their
home invaders is the advantage of being
alive versus their corpse and dragged
out the front door I have I have no
problem with it anymore yeah and this is
where you know the left has lost their
mind they are now on the side of
criminals
kidding me unlawful defensive use of a
firearm okay hey kid you know the road I
got really dark when a different
direction than some people expect it
this is the idea of sympathy of a victim
culture right of the victim culture it
was unfair and so it hurt my son yeah
well you know what if you actually go
along the trail with that victim culture
if you go along with that narrative you
create real victims like homeowners who
now no longer have an unfair advantage
so what happens they get raped or their
throat slit or they get robbed by the
way I'm okay with you being shot even if
your intent is just to rob yeah am I
saying it's the ideal outcome no you
break into somebody's house in the
middle of the night you forfeit your
right to live how do you wanted some
jewelry to buy some crack I don't care
you're gonna see my ar-15 in the house
you cannot separate when people say I'm
against big government I'm against this
but I'm for the free health care you
cannot separate authoritarianism you
cannot separate large state dependents
from the right to self preservation from
erring on the side of freedom you don't
get one without the other and this is
what you see with Germany all right you
want to depend on us for everything well
guess what you're not allowed to protect
yourselves you have to rely on our cops
by the way all cops are racist
so as self-defense in Germany the
mildest means available is what's
necessary to defend an attack that means
that one can't injure somebody more than
necessary that's what they're talking
about in Germany again if you're not
erring on the side of freedom if you're
not erring on the side of personal
responsibility in life liberty pursuit
of happiness the Second Amendment that's
why it's so clear if you don't draw a
line and say no this is one of those
things home invader sorry you forfeit
your right to live this person has the
right to protect themselves if it gets
into gray territory because we love as a
Young Turks loved to say it's
complicated it's nuanced did that could
have a bad day what was the education
like did he have access to the charter
schools he didn't have access to the
church no it's a line in a sin you're in
my house this is my house this is my
family is
my stuff you die now okay because if you
get into the great territory of Germany
well guess what who decides what was the
force necessary well what if the guy
shows up and it's not a real good and
it's a fake gun what if the guy shows up
and it's a knife and you have a gun well
technically you're using more force but
what if the guy is a knife and he's six
foot five and you have to be 5-3 what if
you're a little Jewish man in Germany
and a big old strapping Aryan comes on
it let's bring it home here so this is
that far off from reality right Germany
sorry
you don't get to screw up with all world
wars and then come back and act as
though you take the moral high ground
well now Veen understand there's no more
killing they don't kill our home
invaders oh really what do you do I'm
just so tired of it I'm tired of these
people acting as really take the moral
hydrant and this is so emblematic of the
left why is the left you know we have in
Nevada right now leftist politicians
pushing a law where they want you to be
prosecuted they want the criminal to
have the right to prosecute a home
invader to have about the prosecute and
it sounds silly well that could never
happen it's happened in Germany in the
UK all over Europe you have people right
now who are doing time in prison they're
doing time in national prisons for
defending their wives their children and
their homes and it is remarkable I look
at this reserve water you separate it
left versus right because listen I'm not
a centrist at all okay there's
center-left all the way to extreme
right-wing and that is more reasonable
than even the moderately kind of left
wing of the Democratic Party today I'm
sorry I'll say it because the super far
right-wing believes that you should have
an ar-15 right they believe you have an
ar-15 you have the right to carry that
without so much as a permit I don't
think that that is any more extreme I
think that is far more reasonable than
someone who believes that a serial
rapist should have the right be entitled
to a trial a civil trial against you for
blowing his head off it doesn't require
moderate I'm far right when it comes to
that and I'm I am just dumbfounded at
the left is so dead set against you
maintaining your right as an autonomous
human being maintained in the right to
protect your
life whether it's supporting tacitly
black lives matter riots and looting or
resettling unvetted refugees who come
with record crime in your neighborhoods
either way they vote for that or whether
it's not directly trying to take away
your right to guns as you see what the
hell of us is DC where literally they
were trying to argue that private
citizens have no right to firearms
whatsoever they're not trying to do that
they're trying to give the criminal the
right to sue you for invading your house
I'm sorry if you're a moderate in the
face of this you haven't thought about
these issues son this isn't one of those
well I guess both sides there is no both
sides do you have the right to protect
your and your life yes no throw it out
of court hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you didn't like this
video you should subscribe anyway
because then you can watch the next
video and what you can do is down vote
it and leave a comment that's really
negative you know particularly if it's
something like I don't know maybe anti
somatic even though I'm not Jewish or
something about my hair or something
about my weird nose just leave a really
negative comments that everyone else
around can act like they care